[Applause]
she brought the faces of war and loss to
the powerful in washington
lisa was only four years old she is no
longer with us here is the stroller
ukraine's first lady olena zolonska had
a simple message the u.s can help more
ukrainians survive by sending more air
defense systems
[Music]
weapons that would not be used to wage a
war on somebody's else's land but to
protect one's home and the right to wake
up alive in that home i'm asking for air
defense systems in order for rockets not
to be killed and not to kill children in
their strollers in order for rockets not
to destroy children's rooms and kill
entire families
the u.s has promised to supply ukraine
medium-range air defense systems but so
far has only promised two of the
national advanced surface-to-air missile
systems that's not nearly enough to
cover a country the size of ukraine
at the pentagon promises send four more
highmars rocket launcher systems
that ukraine has used to target russian
ammunition depots and command and
control centers deep behind the front
lines that brings the total from the u.s
to 16.
and the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff played down russia's gains so far
so for 90 days the russian advances have
amounted to maybe six to ten miles
something in that range it's not very
much
it's very intense a lot of violence
tens of thousands of artillery rounds
every 24-hour period
lots of casualties on both sides
the biden administration is expected to
announce the weapons it'll be sending to
ukraine on friday zalenska had a chance
to speak with president joe biden this
week she'll soon find out if her
personal plea was enough to get her
country the weapons she says they
desperately need
patti culhane al jazeera on capitol hill